tom silverstein he covers the Packers
for the Milwaukee Journal Sentinel boy
you got a little drama there in the
offseason thanks for joining us tom
yeah yeah and pretty used to that having
gone through the Favre era and even
makowsky to Favre era so yeah I've been
around a lot of there have been a lot of
quarterbacks witches but there have been
some pretty dramatic ones if you're how
would you sum up the last week here with
the Packers well you know it could be
making more of it but I kind of think
that this is the year that Brian
gudykunst and Matt Lafleur sort of take
back the organization but it's been
central to Aaron Rodgers and you know
Mike McCarthy had a great run and gave
Rodgers a lot of leeway during that time
and now they're there seeing it as okay
how many more years of this is left and
we have to start thinking about you know
the future and not only that you know
Matt Lafleur
was not able to really run his entire
offense last year he married a lot of
stuff that Rodgers was doing with a
Karthi and I think in some ways it
reminds me of that scene and Moneyball
when you know the man or how keeps
playing the guy he wants to play and
Brad Pitt keeps trading the guys away
until he only has that guy to flag and
so he's sort of like okay I got the
running back okay attracted an h-back
and you know we have no choice but to
run but run the ball now because that's
our strength and and I think that's what
he wants to get back to I think he wants
to be a 50% running to him his mentor is
Kyle Shanahan and they drafted a H back
that looks just like Kyle usage and he
drafted a running back that looks like
Derek Henry who he had in Tennessee
so there's some changes going on no I
get that Tom but if I have the most
talented quarterback of all time and all
of a sudden I'm gonna make my team of
running to the reason why the Niners are
a running team is because Jimmy
Garoppolo is not Aaron Rodgers yeah you
know that Tennessee is a running team
because they have Ryan Tannehill you
have Aaron Rodgers that's what I don't
understand where you go this is how we
beat the Niners I just gave some stats
on what happened in the regular season
and the postseason against the Niners
you didn't score and you didn't stop
them
so what did you do in the offseason that
says hey we're gonna score more or we're
gonna be able to stop them Jordan love
it doesn't help you no no he absolutely
does not help you right now but you know
they they addressed the defense last
year they spent a ton of money and
capital and draft picks and they're
expecting it to be better in year two
they expect to be a better defense
although you know I think they have to
change parts of their scheme to do that
but that's a whole nother show I think
what you have is there is their belief
and you know and here's that here's the
rub to it is that you know we all know
Rodgers wasn't happy with McCarthy so
you change a code you have to live with
his new the new philosophy you don't get
to pick the code and what his new
philosophy is going to be and Matt
Lafleur's philosophy is to have a strong
get running game and pass off a
play-action but you got to run the ball
you know a good amount of the time in
order to get Aaron Rodgers all the
really good opportunities of passing the
ball and in that system they don't you
know in Shanahan system even in in
McVeigh which are all the same they they
don't stress big-time wide receivers I
mean the 49ers don't have big-time wide
receivers the Rams have good fast
receivers but they're not you know all
pros
they spent money though they spent money
on their Brandon cooks like they the the
the RAM spent money and tried to upgrade
you know Cooper Cup you know the Niners
you can say that maybe you know they
traded for manual Sanders you got kiddo
who's involved in the offense as well I
just I don't know with with Rogers it is
Rogers there in three years Tom unlikely
I mean after two years they have been
his so he's here this year then two more
years left of proration on his original
guaranteed money that I think it's
thirteen point five or fourteen million
per year so they could do it in after
2021 and still take a little bit of a
hit but not bad I think I think it all
depends I think that what they're saying
is if it's three years it's three years
but we don't know what's going to be
happening in three years
is he difficult to work with though like
Rogers I've been around him but you deal
with him differently is it real or media
created that he is passive aggressive
he's difficult he's a diva all the
things that you hear well I think that
he is established and a lot of the
things he does and he's extremely smart
and it's hard I think for people to be
smarter than him and you know I think
that causes some issues I think every
quarterback sativa you know just like
every wide receivers a diva what what
the degree is you know coach's head
coaches are really reluctant to talk
about that and but I think it's more
about can they you know get him to buy
in all in on the smaller system because
I don't think they did that last year I
think they had a lot of parts that were
McCarthy
you know I'll get to be a couple
examples as they run the clock down you
know Rogers likes to run the clock down
to zero because he wants to know what
the defense is doing wants to wants to
make them make the first move
so pre-read you know pre snappy as a
read that's not a real big staple of the
floors off and he likes tempo he likes
to get the ball out you know snap the
ball he likes a lot of players so that's
one thing you know they want to run a
higher percent they they ran the ball I
think 60 62 percent of the time
something like that they want to run it
closer to 50 so you know Rogers had a
lot of leeway in changing place I just
think those are the kind of things that
they're trying to implement and they
felt like they had to do it through a
message in the draft yeah but it's a
mess it's a silly message to send if you
got a guy who may not play for three
years and you trade up to get a guy
can't can't you send a message in a
different way to Aaron Rodgers do I have
to draft a quarterback who won't unless
he gets hurt he's not going to play for
a couple of years it's just I don't know
maybe I don't understand the front
office of the Packers there so yeah I
think I'm not defending him I'm trying
to explain what their thinking was and I
think their thinking was you know Brian
gudykunst was around when Ted Thompson
took Aaron Rodgers and the end result of
that was good he had a quarterback who
became an all-pro and an MVP and I think
if you have the belief that Jordan love
is that kind of quarterback then you
have to you know you are the keeper of
the organization and as a GM you have to
make that move I don't know what Jordan
loves going to be that guy he could he
could bomb out in in three years but
this is I'm trying to get you inside
Brian Goethe Crimson's head because he's
been through this and I think they're
saying you know you only fall in love
with a quarterback once any
at picking at number 30 you don't get a
chance to get a guy like that and so
that's what they were that's what we're
gonna do and I still think they can win
with Rogers well they are they over
achieve last year Tom they weren't a
thirteen and three team I think you know
third absolutely yeah and I think
because they're way yes absolutely
alright if you can ask Rogers one
question and get an honest answer
what would the question be I think I
think the question would be are you
willing to go all-in
Lafleur's aw shucks and do whatever he
says because you know like I said he
wanted to change and here you go that's
what happens when you know be careful
what you want sometimes you get a coach
with a different offense and a different
idea how to do things so I would want to
know if he's all in on it
Tom good to talk to you we appreciate
your time and congrats on getting well
whatever you feel like it's a scoop or
just a strong inclination here of what's
going on with this situation more to
follow I'm sure with Aaron Rodgers in
the offseason yeah it feels like every
offseason there's something with Aaron
Rodgers but thank you Tom for spending
some time you're very welcome
that's a Tom silverstein he covers the
Packers for the Milwaukee Journal
Sentinel